- 75% Of black
kids in California
can not read at state
levels of proficiency.
50% of all kids in
the public sector,
public universities
in California, K-12,
cannot read at state
levels of proficiency.
I went to Crenshaw High School.
That was the school that was
featured in "Boys in the Hood".
I just checked yesterday.
2% are math proficient,
and it's a school
that's dominated
by the gang called the Crips.
Who the hell sends their
kid to a high school
where only 2% are
math proficient
and a school that's dominated
by Crips if they can get out?
The majority of inner city
parents, black and brown,
both want choice but they
keep pulling that lever
for Democrats that don't
give them a choice.
(upbeat music)
- All right, I'm in
studio with Larry Elder.
That was the shortest
intro I've ever--
- Booya.
- Good to see you, my man.
- Nice to see you too.
- All right, we just
did a quick live stream
because there's a little sort
of up in the air situation
as to whether you're
going to actually be
on the recall ballot.
You are running for
governor of California.
We're going to
conduct this interview
as if you are gonna
be on the ballot.
I believe you are going to be.
- I'm gonna be on the
ballot, I've got good lawyers
and people say
possession of a law,
possession is 9/10 of
the law, no it's not.
Possession of a good
lawyer is 9/10 of the law.
I got good lawyers and
we're going to beat this.
- Okay, so let's
just drop all that.
You're going to
be on the ballot.
You did it.
You decided to get in the game.
I had people begging me.
There's a gagillion people out
there, like fix California.
Nobody ever, no good people,
decent people ever
want to get in.
What finally drag you to do it?
- So many people, like you,
approached me and said
why don't you do this?
Dennis Prager first asked me
and I said, "Dennis, hell no."
And he said, "Why?"
I said, "California is
practically ungovernable."
We have 2/3 super
majority in the Senate,
2/3 super majority
in the assembly,
plus a left wing governor,
the environmentalist
run this state,
the teacher's union
dominate this state.
It's almost
ungovernable, hell no.
Dennis goes, "Oh,
okay, I understand."
And then I got approached by
a guy named Pastor Jack Hibbs,
also a very good friend of mine.
And he made the same
argument Dennis did.
And then a friend of mine,
named Lionel Chetwin,
a long-time filmmaker also
made the same argument
and then just normal people
that I know in my life,
my gardener, the guy that
drives me from time to time,
the guy that opened the
door when I come into my,
to my office buildings
from time to time,
people that I work
with and nobody said,
"Well, Larry, geez,
you have a great life
"and my goodness, you're
starting to make money now
"and you've got a
long time relationship
"with your girlfriend, Nina,
why jeopardize all that?
"And nobody's lived
a perfect life
"and I'm sure you
haven't too why expose?"
No one said that!
I kept waiting for somebody
I respect to say that.
My mother and my father
are no longer with us.
My brother just died,
he was my best friend.
He died September 13, 2019,
two weeks before
his 70th birthday
and I know what
he would've said.
He would've said go for
it, that's just how he is.
My mom would have
said, go for it.
My dad would have been more
reluctant about my own privacy
and my own career, but my mother
would have said go for it.
She's been more
political than I am.
So I couldn't--
I ran out of reasons
not to do it.
And the more I
watched Gavin Newsom,
the more he ticked me off.
The way he was sitting
at that restaurant,
called the French Laundry.
Dave, I've never even of that
restaurant until he was there.
I thought it was probably
the most elite restaurant
in California, it's not.
I thought it was most elite
restaurant in America, it's not,
It's one of the most elite
restaurants in the world.
And here he is sitting
there incurring a tab.
Some people say it's 12 grand.
I heard it was high as 30 grand,
with the very medical
professionals and the lobbyists
that drafted the mandates
that they were violating
by not wearing masks and
by not socially distancing.
- At the height of lockdown,
this wasn't two weeks.
- And his two kids were enjoying
in-person private education
and he exempted his own winery
from the mandates and this
kind of arrogant, smug,
entitled attitude really
started taking me off.
And then you add to that, the
crime and the homelessness
and the hellacious cost
of living in California.
My dad came to California in
1945, right after the war.
He's from Athens, Georgia and
he came out here on a run.
He was a Pullman porter
and he was amazed
you could walk into the
front door of a restaurant
and get served.
And he kind of thought maybe
someday I'll make a mental note
and come back to California.
Pearl Harbor, my dad
joined the Marines.
I said, dad, why the Marines?
He said two reasons.
They go where the action
is and I love the uniforms.
My dad was in charge of cooking
for the colored soldiers.
He was a staff sergeant.
My dad could look at a cake
Dave, and tell you what's in it.
that's how good he is.
He goes back to Chattanooga
where he met and married my mom
and he's going to get him a
job as a short order cook.
So he goes to restaurant, to
restaurant, to restaurant,
and he's told to his face,
we don't hire niggers.
Goes to the unemployment office,
the lady says you went
through the wrong door.
My dad sees "colored
only" in the hall,
goes through that door
to the very same lady
who sent him out.
She just wanted him to
know what the rules were.
He goes back to my mom
and said, this is BS.
I'm going to LA where
I'd been on a run.
I'm gonna get me a job as a cook
and I'll send for you
in a couple of days.
Dad comes out,
walks around for a day and a
half and he's told, I'm sorry,
you don't have any references.
My dad said, I need references
to make ham and eggs?
So he goes to unemployment
office this time, just one door,
and the lady says,
I have nothing.
My dad says, what
time do you open?
She says, nine, what
time do you close?
She said five.
My dad said, I'll be
sitting in that chair
until you find something.
Sat there for one day, came
back, sat there for half a day.
She calls him up, sir,
I've got something.
I don't think you're
going to want it.
My dad said, of course, I'm
going to want it, what is it?
She said it's job
cleaning toilets
at Nabisco Brand Bread.
My dad did that for 10 years.
Took a second job at
another bread company,
called BarbaraAnn Bread.
You're too young to remember
that company, it's now defunct.
Two jobs, 10 years, full
time cleaning toilets,
saved up enough
money to buy a house
in south central Los Angeles
that is now valued at $600,000.
I just checked with
Zillow the other day.
Wonderful for us because
it's in our family,
but somebody, 8th grade dropout,
could not duplicate
my dad's success
from the poverty
of the middle-class
if he or she worked three jobs.
That's how bad the cost of
living has become in California.
The average price in
California is 150% more
than the average
price in America
and according to Leo Haney,
and one of the many experts
that I've interviewed
on my radio show over the years,
he's brilliant econ
professor at UCLA,
he says houses in
California are 50% more
than they would be, but
for the environmental laws
and the extremists that
have been using them
to stop construction of housing,
which is why we have
a housing shortage,
it's why so many young people
are leaving California,
going to places like Tennessee
and Florida and Texas.
There's a magazine Dave,
called "CEO" magazine,
don't know if you're
familiar with it.
They've been around 17
years and based upon things
like taxes, spending,
unfunded pension liabilities,
the power of public
sector unions
and the degree to which
the business climate
is friendly or not friendly,
California had been rated
number 50 of all 50 states
for the entire 17 years "CEO"
magazine has been published.
It is outrageous and this guy
is doing nothing
at all about it.
- Okay, so that
story starts however,
with your dad coming out here,
because things were
better out here.
What went wrong here and
when did it get wrong
and did something snap, you
think, in the last two years,
'cause of lockdown
that really like,
pushed it over the edge?
- Well, yeah, to answer the
latter part of your question,
it was a lockdown because
of the way Gavin Newsom
imposed these mandates
against science
and the way the Teacher's
Union kept getting paid
while telling kids not to go
back to in-school learning,
even if the CDC
said it was okay.
75% of black kids in
California cannot read
at state levels of proficiency.
50% of all kids in
the public sector,
public universities
in California, K-12,
can not read at state
levels of proficiency.
I went to Crenshaw High School,
that was the school that was
featured in "Boys in the Hood".
I just checked yesterday,
2% are math proficient
and it's a school
that's dominated
by the gang called the Crips,
Who the hell sends their
kid to a high school
where only 2% are
math proficient
and a school that's dominated
by Crips if they can get out?
The majority of inner city
parents, black and brown,
both want choice, but they
keep pulling that lever
for democrats that
don't give them choice.
Explain that to me.
And when I've talked to black
media and I just did that
the other day in Sacramento,
I said, aren't you tired?
Aren't you tired of the
fact that 75% of black kids
cannot read at state
level proficiency?
Aren't you tired of the
fact that an LAUSD teacher,
Los Angeles unified
public school teacher,
who have school-aged
kids is twice as likely
as non-family,
non-teaching families
to put their own kids
in private school?
44% of Philadelphia public
school teachers, Dave,
with school-aged kids
have their own kids
in private school, as opposed
to 10% of families nationwide,
6% of black families nationwide.
It's the equivalent of
opening up a restaurant,
putting up a sign and
saying, come on in,
just don't eat the food.
(men laughing)
- What are we
talking about here?
I said, aren't
you tired of this?
Aren't you tired of
badmouthing the cops
and the cops are pulling back
and the people who are hurt
are the very same people
that the left claims
that they care about,
aren't you tired of this?
- So what is that disconnect?
I mean, I asked
this to basically,
all my guests at this point.
What is the disconnect
between voting lefty policies
and then not understanding
that it's those policies
that are doing the damage?
- Because people by and
large, are not policy wonks,
like you and I are.
They're not looking at
this, they're working.
They're trying to put
food on the table.
So people leave
and go to Oregon.
They go to places and all
of a sudden those states
become more left wing, and
they bring their policies
with them because they
haven't connected the dots.
There's a reason why
houses are so high.
It's called CEQA, the California
Quality Environmental Act
that basically stopped any
project for any reason,
for almost an indefinite
period of time.
In preparing for this race
I talked to a lot of
developers and contractors
and the stories they told me.
Larry, I had a 2,000
home development project
all ready to roll, I got sued.
I cut it down to a
thousand, I got sued.
I cut it down to
five and I got sued.
Now it's 200 homes,
22 years later.
I talked to one guy who
made all of his money
buying gas stations and
when I say talked to,
I'm on the phone
trying to raise money.
75% of being a politician
is raising money, ha.
And I call him and
I introduced myself.
I said my name is
Larry Elder, who?
Didn't know who I was.
I'm on radio 30 years
in California in
every major market.
Didn't know who I was.
Pretty ego settling.
- A couple of viral videos
with that Dave Rubin guy.
- Tell me about it.
He didn't know who
you were either.
And I said, haven't you
seen me on Dave Rubin?
He goes, who?
And I said,
one of the things I'm going
to do when I become governor
is I'm going to call
a state emergency
and I'm going to suspend CEQA.
And he goes, what's your name?
CEQA was suspended
for the construction
of the Sacramento Kings
stadium up in Sacramento.
For a billionaire,
somehow they wave CEQA,
but for people that
want to build houses.
So the average person leaving
California doesn't realize
that stopping
construction, of course,
means it's going to
be a deficit of homes,
economics 101 supply and demand,
and as a result, a
fewer, fewer supply,
the demand goes up
and the prices go up.
So young people can't
get their starter home
the way my father was able to do
with an 8th grade education
and people are leaving.
They don't understand
the connection between
the declining public schools
and the fact that you literally
cannot fire a teacher.
Derek Chauvin, by the way,
however you feel about
how that trial turned out,
had about 15 serious
complaints against him.
They couldn't get rid of him.
Same thing with the teachers.
There were 300,000
public school teachers
in the state of California.
I am told by experts
that between 5-7% of them
are incompetent, which
means a minimum of 15,000
need to be fired.
You know how many people
were fired last year?
Two, two and took millions
of dollars for that to happen
and they end up in
the worst schools.
I subscribed to spectrum cable.
It used to irritate me
how it defaults to
the LA Times Channel.
- I swear to you, that's
why I got rid of cable,
because they would, every
time you turn on the box,
it would send you
to their channel.
- What you had the night
before it is there.
But after you sitting
there, you're captive
and every now and then
I'm watching this stuff
and when I decided to run
for office it's local,
so I wanted to get
more into local issues.
And the other day,
two or three days ago,
there's this black woman
who started her own school.
And it turns out
2/3 of black parents
do not want to send
their kids back to LAUSD.
They've seen how bad
the education was
because they were able
to watch it online
and they are ticked off
and they believe there
is systemic racism,
but not the normal kind
of systemic racism,
because most of the teachers
and the administrators
are black.
They believe the worst teachers
and the worst
administrative end up
in the inner city schools where
they need the best teachers
and the best administrators
and they believe
that's systemic racism.
So they want out, I'm the
one I want to get you out.
But I'm an Uncle Tom
and I'm a sell-out.
Think about it,
connect the dots.
It's a reason for this.
- Okay, so on the
dots, the dots I think,
in terms of the
zeitgeists of America
have been being connected.
'Cause you've been talking
about the family stuff forever
and that you got to
stop throwing money
at all these things, there do
seem to be more red-pilled,
former lefties, like me,
that perhaps because of the
video that you and I did,
where you beat me senseless
and everyone's seen it already,
but people woke up, right?
So in that regard, are
you feeling hopeful
that maybe in place in pockets
of say the black community,
that weren't open
to these ideas?
- I am absolutely hopeful.
I believe I can
explain things in ways
that Joe and Joe
six pack can get.
Again, it's not
because they're stupid.
It's because they're working,
they're putting
food on the table.
They're trying to get
that first starter home.
But they don't realize that
the connection between this
and all the problems that
they're complaining about.
We talked about homelessness.
What does Gavin Newsom
and the democrats
want to do about homelessness?
Build homes for the homeless
at a cost 3, 4, 5 times
than what the private
sector could do, A,
and B not dealing with
the underlying problem,
why they're homeless
in the first place.
So even if they were able to
get up and go to the homes,
they wouldn't stay.
Meanwhile, you're sending a
signal to the other states,
cold weather climates.
I can go to California
where the weather is nice
and people are going
to treat me humanely
and I get a free
home, come on down!
And that's what's happening.
I talked to cops who
tell me that many people
on skid row aren't
even from here.
- Yeah, we know that
they're coming now.
So when you see that
places like Venice,
that was used to, Venice Beach,
was the coolest, gorgeous place.
- Trendy, bohemian.
- It's a disaster right
now, drugs everywhere.
- Right, needles everywhere.
And one of the reasons
because of proposition 47,
that the voters in California,
foolishly voted for,
which meant that if you
steal at 9.50 or less--
By the way, you can
do it every day,
you're not going to go to jail
because you'll be
committing a misdemeanor
and if they catch you,
they'll give you a ticket.
The whole point was, and it
was a legit legitimate point,
was to get people in treatment
because many people who
are stealing are stealing
to support their meth habit,
but you take away the
stick of going to jail.
There's no reason
to go to rehab.
So the cops were saying,
get up and go to rehab.
F-you, why should I go,
what are you gonna do to me?
Nothing!
- So what do we about the DA's
'cause that's part
of it too, right?
- We have two left-wing DAs.
One in the bay area San
Francisco and one in L.A.
and by the way, they're
both facing recall elections
and I also avidly support
the recall of those two DA's
because they're soft on crime.
And this mow mowing
of the police,
the police are pulling back.
It's called the Ferguson effect.
Now they call it the
George Floyd effect.
You're a cop, much of police
work is discretionary.
You don't have to get out of
the car if you don't want to.
You see something
that looks suspicious,
why get out of the
car and run the risk
someone's going to
get their cell phone,
video you and accuse
you of systemic racism?
So they stay in the car.
They're answering radio
calls and that's it.
Bad guys know it,
crime is going up.
Guess who gets hurt?
Black and brown people, the
very people that the left
claims they care about.
- So if let's say you win.
- When I win, when you win.
Please, don't be so negative.
- No, no, I'm I'm with you.
- You said, let's say,
it's hypothetical.
Hypotheticals out here.
After you win, comma.
You want me to sit over there
and I can interview myself?
What are we doing over
here, come on, talk to me.
- Right before we started,
I said you're my OB1
and I'm Princess Leah now,
you're my only hope man.
This is it if I'm going
to stay in this crazy,
in this crazy city and
in this crazy state.
But what would you be
modeling this after?
I mean, would you
want California
to basically be modeled
after say what DeSantis
is doing in Florida?
Like, does that look
like a good model to you?
- Well, yes it does,
but what I'm going to do
when I become governor, I've
had a lot of conversations--
- [Dave] When, when.
- I did that for you,
I did that for you.
When I become governor,
I've talked to a lot of
people who are people
that were in the
administration that Pete Wilson
of Dukmejian, two Republican
governors in the past,
and you'd be amazed how
much power the governor has,
even dealing with a
hostile legislature.
Of course you can veto,
his line item veto.
There is the ability to
declare a public emergency
and that ability has been used
many times by this governor
to impose all these
anti-science mandates.
There is a public emergency
of housing shortage.
There's a public
emergency of homelessness.
emergency of schools.
I'm going to impose
public emergencies
to get rid of
these bad teachers,
to suspend CEQA so that people
will not be afraid to build.
20,000 prisoners
have been released
under the supervision of
this man, Gavin Newsom,
under early release for COVID.
So they're releasing felons
while treating builders
and contractors like felons.
It's ridiculous.
I'm going to reverse that.
- Do you think that Gavin
Newsom thinks he's doing well?
- Well, how many interviews
have you seen Gavin Newsom
have in the last several months?
- We've reached out
a million dollars.
- Of course not.
How's he going to
defend rising crime?
How's he going to defend
these crappy schools
he wouldn't put his
own kids in on a bet?
How's he going to defend
basically buying a home
for homeless at 10
times or five times
the cost of what the
private sector can do?
How's he going to defend
any of that? He cannot.
how ticked off people are
about the arrogant way
he shut down the state
in the most severe way
than any of the other
50 governors have done?
He can't defend that,
he doesn't want you.
In the 33 years that
Buckley had his show
called, "Firing Line".
The last day he ended
the show somebody said,
why didn't Ted Robert
Kennedy and all the times
you extended him an
invitation, come on your show?
And Buckley said, why does
the baloney avoid the grinder?
He doesn't want you,
he doesn't want me.
He can't defend that.
He's not going to debate me.
Are you kidding,
are you kidding?
- So what do you need to happen?
What do you think, you're
on the ballot, like,
what do you think has to happen
over the course of the next--
- I need money.
- It's not a ton of time.
- I, I need, I need money.
When I was induced to run
by people that I
like and respect--
- By the way speaking, you
mentioned Prager before,
I said to Prager in my
backyard months ago,
I said, Dennis run,
I'll fundraise for you.
You could have parties
here, whatever.
Everything I can
do on my channel.
- What'd he say?
- He goes, get Larry Elder.
- Get Larry Elder to do it,
get the black guy to do it.
And Dennis is also responsible
for my career on radio.
But for Dennis, I
met him in Cleveland
when I was working.
I'm from here, but I
met him in Cleveland
and Dennis put me on his show.
Management heard me
the rest is history.
And Dennis also induced
me to get into this race.
I told Dennis this
morning I was on his show.
I said, "Dennis, you're
going to burn in hell."
What are we talking about?
- We're all going together.
- I lost my train of thought.
- No, so in the two months
now it's it's money.
Okay, so you got it your mind.
- Okay, so I was told
by people like Dennis
and people like pastor
Jackie and others,
Larry, because of
your celebrity,
because of your social
media profile platform,
you got 2.5 million, I think
you have a little bit more.
- Yeah, they're screwing
you on Twitter, by the way.
You're like right
up there on that,
- Have a channel called Larry
Elder Epic Times Channel.
I have 575,000 followers.
I've had that same
number for almost a year.
It was rocking and rolling
and then all of a
sudden, dead stop.
- Yeah, no, I know, because
me and you were both
at like 980 on Twitter and I
was like, I want to beat him.
- Not that we're competitive
or anything like that.
- No, no, no!
You know, you beat
me once publicly.
So I was like, I got to
get to a million before him
and then they just
keep, get you.
- So the whole thing
is about money.
That's why I'm urging people
to go to electelder.com.
Notice how I didn't work
that in until just now?
- No, no it's subtle.
- I waited on it.
I started to do it
right away but I said,
you know, Dave, well.
- That was electelder--
- Electelder.com, yes.
And so I was told, unlike
the average politician,
you're not going to be on
the phone 75% of the time
raising money because
you're so well known
and all I have to do is tell
people that you're going to run
and all of a sudden the
money's gonna come flooding in.
I'm on the phone with 75% of
the time trying to raise money,
just like any other politician.
There's a $34,200 limit max
individual contribution,
I'm sure you're going
to be making that, Dave.
- Well, I'll have to
talk my accountant.
My accountant's
over here, you know.
- But Gavin Newsom does not
have spending limitations
nor raising limitations.
He can spin and raise as
much money as possible.
Shortly after it was obvious--
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
So the incumbent can
raise whatever they want
from whoever they want?
- But yeah, by the way,
the five-year tax stuff
that I had to return, that
that is apparently the problem
by my getting on
the ballot, again,
that's going to be
overturned, I'm sure,
does not apply to him.
He does not have to turn
over five years of his taxes.
Just the rivals.
- I'll put that one aside,
but why doesn't the incumbent
have any limitations
on what he can-
- You tell me. It's California.
- What a town, man.
We are in La-La Land.
- Chinatown Jake.
But I do, I have limitations
on more than that.
I cannot win unless I get
money from people in California
and outside California, who
recognize how California goes.
So goes the rest of the country.
And I want "millionaires
and billionaires",
to quote Bernie Sanders,
set up PACS along the lines
of my philosophy
about school choice,
about what to do about crime,
what to do about homelessness
so that I can spend beyond that.
Otherwise, I'm not going to win.
Shortly after it was
obvious I was going to run,
a union gave this
man $5 million.
So without getting
money from other people
and outside other people to
set up little action committee,
it's along the lines
of my philosophy,
I don't have any hope
of beating this guy.
- So you consider yourself a
small L libertarian, right?
- Yes, yes.
I've always been that and
I'm a registered Republican.
And the reason I registered
as Republican, about,
I think it was 12 years ago,
is I was going to run
against Barbara Boxer.
I wasn't gonna run
against as a libertarian.
They always lose.
And by the way, this is
kind of one of the reasons
I want to go into politics,
I had such such a
bad experience then.
Ten they said, go
to Washington, DC,
meet the Senate people, John
Cornyn, who's still there,
and Inhofe from
Oklahoma is still there,
and just show them
how charming you are,
give them your backstory
and then they'll back you
as the official candidate
and the money will come in.
I fly to DC on my own dime.
I didn't want there
to be any shenanigans
and I sit there
with, with Cornyn.
I tell them about my background
and talk about my father
and how he came to
California in 1945,
he was a Marine and all this.
And they're, (mouth noises).
I thought I'd won them over.
I get back to LAX, phone rings,
we're going with Carly Fiorina.
I said, why, they
said three reasons.
One, she's a woman.
I said, well, I'm not
gonna have a sex to run.
Number two, she has
more money than you.
I said, I give you that.
Number three, she has higher
name recognition than you do.
I said, no, she doesn't.
She does in DC because she
was CEO of Hewlett Packard.
But nobody knows her
out here in California.
She lost by 10 points and
didn't put nearly as much money
into her campaign
as they thought.
So that was my only
foray into politics.
Other than when I ran
against William Maury
for fifth grade class president.
- How'd you do?
- I took three out of four rows,
they're still
cleaning up the blood.
So I just was turned off by
the whole thing about politics.
- Yeah, well, I know you--
- And how duplicitous it is.
And many people I thought were
gonna give me money didn't
and those who didn't think
was gonna give me money did.
And I'm still surprised
all the time by the games
that people play and the
shenanigans people play.
But I am now old enough
and I think wise enough and
experienced enough in life
to understand these
things are gonna happen.
I was asked many times,
what is your experience
for running for governor?
And I said, what does
Gavin Newsom's experience?
- He was mayor of San Francisco.
He was eight years--
- Eight years, ruined it!
- Eight years,
Lieutenant Governor,
two years of current governor.
How's he doing?
There was a fellow who ran for
governor, served two terms,
ran for president
served two terms.
His name is Ronald Reagan
came out of the movie industry
for crying out loud.
I've got common sense,
I got good judgment,
I'm a native California,
I'm a product of public schools,
I know what's wrong with them.
I have got ideas what to
do about homelessness.
I know what we
can do about crime
and I know we can do
about the cost of living.
So when I become governor,
I'm going to use my powers
to declare emergencies
for many of these issues.
We have the same
water infrastructure
and the same power
infrastructure as we had
when California was
half the population.
Because if you stick
a spoon in the ground,
someone's going to
sue you claiming
has had an adverse
environmental impact under CEQA.
I'm going to stop all that crap.
- So, when Newsom's
doing all of this,
like the average person,
especially during lockdowns,
I would go to a lot of the
rallies to open up the state
and I was meeting, you know,
people that own restaurants
and people that own businesses
that they were not political,
they certainly were
not Republicans,
but they were mugged
basically, mugged by reality.
And they were going, I
just want to go to work.
I have a feeling a lot
of them can be broken
and they can move to say
the conservative side
or Republican or
Larry Elder thing.
But what do you think is,
do you think there's
something else you got to do
to get them to make
that final jump?
- Well, that's why
I need the money.
I need to be on television.
California is a
big, big, big state,
and you need to be on TV
and you need to be on radio.
But Dave, it doesn't take
long find horror stories.
I mean, literally they
just come up to you.
I don't even have
to go look for them.
The other day I'm shooting
a commercial for my ads,
for running for office.
Makeup lady's
putting stuff on me.
We're both bored, waiting for
them to set everything up.
So I'm talking, I
said, tell me about you
and she goes, well,
I'm a single mom
and I have a 17 year old son.
He is one of the top 25
wrestlers in California
for his weight class.
Was wrestling six days a week
and his coach was
his father figure.
The coach begged them not
to shut down the school
and to keep, wanted these kids
to keep having the
structure they were having.
So now the kid is in
the home with his mom,
cooped up month after month
after month after month,
kid becomes morose,
become sullen.
He had enough integrity and
a good enough relationship
with his mom that he
went up to her and said,
"Mom, I feel suicidal."
He's now in therapy.
Another person on my
campaign had a brother
living in Oakland.
Had is the important word.
He was a football
coach, white guy,
most of all of his
players are black,
coming from fatherless homes.
He was their father figure.
They practice six days a
week, he gave them structure.
Hegged them not to shut
down the school system.
These kids need
to have structure.
Two of them got into
trouble with the law,
one of whom had committed
a crime so serious,
he's gonna be in
prison for years.
It would not have had to
happen, in his opinion,
had they had the same
structure that he had before.
He got so ticked off
he's now in Tennessee,
resuming his football
coaching career.
There, not here.
- I read a piece in the
LA Times a day or two ago
about ya and you know, it was
something like Trump acolyte,
something like that,
Larry Elder thing.
And it ends in the
most, I mean, it's,
the media is so awful.
Like, nothing surprises
me at this point,
but like the last
line was in effect,
and there was Larry
Elder once again,
defending white people,
something to that effect,
I'm loosely quoting it.
- She also said Larry has
been falsely using crime stats
about black people.
Didn't say what crime
stats I was falsely using.
And the one she's talking
about is when I told her
that the number one cause
of preventable death
for young white men is
accidents, like car accidents,
drowning accidents.
The number one cause
of preventable death
for young black men is homicide
almost always at the hands
of another young black man.
Now, unless you're prepared
to say black people
are just genetically inclined
to commit more crime,
you have to ask yourself what
the blank is going on here.
And the answer is
fatherless homes.
There's the direct line
between all these problems
we're talking about and
kids coming from homes
without a father and
forget about Elder,
I think I gave you
this stat before.
Obama once said that a kid
raised without a father
is five times more likely
to be poor and commit crime,
nine times more likely
to drop out of school
and 20 times more likely
to end up in prison.
Now, how have we gone
from 25% of black kids
being born outside of
wedlock in 1965 to 70% now?
You're telling me that
America is more racist now
than it was in 1965?
And the answer is
a welfare state.
What we've done--
- Well, their
answer would be yes,
but your answer is
welfare state, right.
They would say yes,
it's because America
kept getting more racist.
- Yeah, kept
getting more racist.
After Obama gets
elected and reelected.
It's kind of a tough
argument to make with them,
but they make that argument.
And the fact is we've
incentivized women
to marry the government.
We've allowed men to
abandon their financial
and moral responsibility.
That's why we have
these problems.
And speaking of racism
and you're quite right,
the democrats are really
pulling out the race card now
because Donald Trump
improved the percentage
of black vote from 8% to
12%, from 2016 to 2020.
That's a 50% increase and
they are scared to death.
In 27 Gallup did a poll.
Obama is running for the
nomination against Hillary
and Mitt Romney's running
for the nomination
on the Republican side
against John McCain.
What percentage of
Americans, Gallop asked,
would not vote for
somebody who's black? 5%.
What percentage would not vote
for somebody who's a woman? 11%.
What percentage would
not vote for somebody
who's a Mormon? 24%.
What percentage would
not vote for somebody
who would be 72 when
he became president,
and that'd be John McCain, 42%.
So Obama had a lower hurdle
than these three
white politicians.
What are we talking about here?
Grow up, knock it off.
- There's a sociologist at
Harvard, he's still there,
his name is Orlando Patterson.
Back in 1991, he said
America, despite his flaws,
is the least racist majority
white society in the world,
provides more opportunities
for all, for blacks,
than any other
country in the world,
including all of
those of Africa.
That was 1991, well,
before Obama got elected.
Last time I was on CNN,
I reminded Don Lemon
of a poll study that was done
by Time magazine and CNN,
of black teens and white
teens, they asked them both,
is racism a major
problem in American?
Both of them said yes.
And then they asked a follow
up question to the black teens.
I never seen anybody
do this before.
Is racism a big problem,
a minor problem,
or no problem in
your own daily life?
89% of black teens said
it was a minor problem
or no problem in
my own daily life.
In fact, twice as many
black teens said, quote,
failure to take advantage
of available opportunities
is a bigger problem than
racism, end of quote.
That was 23 years ago, what
are we talking about here?
Knock it off, knock it off!
These guys are playing the
race card because they know
that they have to scare
up a 13% of black people
and a bunch of
liberal white people
into believing that racism
remains a major problem
because they pull that
lever for them 95%,
until Donald Trump came along
and said what do
you have to lose?
- Larry, you've blown me away
once or twice over the years,
but are you telling me
that the conservatives
are not racist?
Are you, are you telling
me that the conservatives
don't hate gay people and
that the conservatives
generally want to
live and let live?
Is that, is that
what you're dropping?
- That's what I'm saying.
Most people want people to
realize their potential.
Why would it be in
anybody's best interest
for a group of people to be,
to perceive them as racist?
How is that making
things better?
Don't you want everybody
to be law abiding,
drug abstaining,
tax-paying people?
Doesn't that make
everything good?
And whenever I ask people
about systemic racism
and I always say,
can you name names?
What do you get, David Duke?
After that the list is
pretty short, isn't it?
Give me the name.
Who in Congress on
the republican side
is systemically racist?
Give me the name,
give me the name.
And sometimes they say,
Trump, are you kidding me?
Best economy ever under Trump,
he pardoned Jack Johnson,
the first black heavyweight
champion, that Obama didn't do
despite the fact that Ken Burns,
the lefty, a documentarian,
came to Obama and said,
please pardon this guy.
Didn't do it.
Sylvester Stallone, please
pardon this guy, didn't do it.
Trump does it.
He also commuted the sentence
of a woman named Alice Johnson.
- [Dave] I met her, I met
her on the Trump Hotel.
- Very long, nonviolent
drug offense.
He put permanent funding of
historically black colleges
on for tenure footing.
No one else had
done that before.
Expanded opportunity zones,
dropping some of the
rules and regulations
in distressed areas so that
you invite more business.
If he is a racist, he needs
to go back to racism school.
- When you were watching
the State of the Union
and he mentioned lowest black
unemployment of all time
and then to watch the
congressional black caucus
sat there like this.
Like to me, that was everything
that you've preached about
in your 40 years doing this.
How many years you've
been on air at this point?
- 27.
I gave you an extra 14.
- But in all of those years--
- Black don't crack.
- You're looking good,
you're looking good.
But when you watch that moment,
it must've just been like,
man, I have been screaming
about this stuff,
here's the guy doing this
stuff and they dare sit there.
- But it's just
one little example.
They've been doing
this for years.
Obama's mom sent him
back from Indonesia
when he was 10 years old to
eventually go to PoonaHo,
the finest prep school
in the state of Hawaii
because she wanted him
to have better education.
Michelle Obama did not
go to a charter school,
they didn't exist then,
but she did not go
to her local government
school because it was so bad.
She got on the bus and went
to a much better school.
Ice Cube, the rapper,
he didn't go to his
local government school,
he went to Taft, which at the
time was predominantly white.
So what are they telling you?
They're telling you
they want choice,
but you don't get choice.
And they're beholden
to the teacher's union
that adamantly opposes
choice for all the reasons
I just now mentioned.
They don't get their automatic
dues from the teacher's union
and therefore it threatens them.
They couldn't care less about
the quality of education.
And I mentioned that
300,000 teachers
in public school
teachers in California
in the average year
only 2.2 are fired.
Imagine I told you
between 5-7% of them
were perceived to
be incompetent.
There are 20,000
cops here in LA.
Imagine if 5% of
them were bad cops.
That's a thousand
cops on the streets.
We wouldn't put up with it.
But we put up with
15,000 bad teachers?
Who wants to do
something about that?
We do, they don't, but I'm the
bad guy, I'm the Uncle Tom.
Think about it, open up your
eyes, who's on your side?
Now the beauty of
our private ballots
is you can go in there and
you're a mail-in ballot
and you can vote
for a republican
and nobody has to know about it.
So I'm telling you
these independents
and democrats pull
the lever for me.
Don't tell anybody.
Who's on your side?
I'm on your side.
- I'm gonna tell people,
I'm going to tell people.
Well, let's talk about
elections for a little bit,
because I voted for Trump during
the presidential election.
I voted against all of the
tax increases that they wanted
to throw out on us
here in Cali and in LA,
but I don't have to show an ID
and I was actually quite
amazed because then I thought,
well, I could just walk back.
All you need is your
name and your address.
I could be my neighbor
and vote the next day
and the next day, the next day.
How, broken do you think the
whole system at this point
and actually related to
California specifically,
are you confident
that once you're in
and that the election
will even be legit
in such a broken state?
- Well, I'm confident.
If it isn't again,
I got good lawyers.
People say possession
of a as I said,
possession is 9/10 of the law,
possession of a good
lawyer is 9/10 of the law.
I've got good lawyers.
Regarding Trump, if I may,
a number of reporters,
what are you gonna
do about the fact
that you voted for Trump?
Well, I'm a republican.
I've voted for
Trump over Hillary.
I should apologize for that?
The last time I voted for
a democrat was Jimmy Carter
and I regret that.
And I will vote for whoever
is a standard bear in 2024.
You're not running
against Trump.
You're running, Gavin Newsom's
running against Larry Elder
and that's what they try and do,
what Gavin Newsom
and his people said
when this thing got certified,
this is all being driven
by white nationalists.
Now, Dave, you've known
me now for a few years,
I'm a lot of things,
but do I look like white
nationalist to you?
- Not a white--
- Not a white one!
- You in your robe in
the Hollywood Hills
with your red wine, not
a white nationalist.
But what do we do?
But are you confident that
an election would be legit
in a state that we know
is so deeply corrupt
from the democrats?
- Well, I, having
been not included
on the ballot for these
ridiculous reasons,
I'm a little worried.
They're scared to death.
The unions are scared.
The public sector unions
in particular are scared.
Remember when Scott Walker
did the union reform
and reduced their
bargaining to wages,
but not benefits and
not discipline and not--
- [Dave] All hell broke loose.
- Right and he also made them,
if you're going to get a raise
beyond 2%, beyond inflation,
you need to go to the
polls and ask the voters.
He stopped the automatic
deduction of union dues.
I'm going to do all of that too.
And they showed him his house
and they picketed his house
and they threatened him.
- Took over the state capitol.
Wasn't an insurrection
when they did it.
- Course not, no,
it was just a--
- Was just a friendly gathering.
- A civil disturbance.
And it's gonna happen to me.
It's going to happen to
my house too. Bring it.
I've been asked, Larry, are
you afraid of being unpopular?
I'm a guy who's been called an
Uncle Tom and the boot licker
and a sellout and a
bug-eyed-boot-licking-sellout
for 27 years.
But what they rarely
call me is wrong.
That's the word I
fear the most, wrong.
They don't say that.
So bring it, hold my beer.
- You're happy at all this.
I mean, that's why I love you
because you're also just
happy in all of this.
You're fighting for
stuff you believe in.
- Because unlike the left,
I don't believe if you disagree
with me you're a bad person.
That's how they think of us.
If you don't believe that
racism is a major problem
in America, you're a bad person.
If you don't believe that taxes
should be raised on rich people,
you're a bad human being.
If you don't believe that
the court should be stacked
with a bunch of people who
think like Sonia Sotomayor,
you're a bad person.
I don't feel that way about you.
I just believe that
you are ill informed.
You haven't met anybody like me.
My mom was a democrat.
My brother was a democrat.
Both of them, I got
them both to vote
for George W. Bush twice.
They still didn't change
their party affiliation,
but I got them to
vote the right way.
They can tell anybody.
So I don't think
you're a bad person.
You're just ill-informed.
And I believe that the
captain of the Titanic, Dave,
had he known that
iceberg was there,
he would have taken
evasive action.
I think a lot of people don't
realize the iceberg is there,
but once they do it,
they will take evasive.
It's up to me to explain
to them, connect the dots,
explain to them why we
need choice in school,
why the cost of
living is so high
and what can be done about it,
what we can do
about homelessness.
It's up to me to explain that
and I believe I can do that
in a way that Joe and
Joan six-pack can do
better than almost anybody else,
because I'm a communicator.
And I thought about these
ideas and I've written
a column every week,
since April of 1998.
I've written a
half a dozen books
discussing these
kinds of things.
I'm on in every major market,
up and down California,
from Sacramento to San Diego
and I believe I can accomplish
this in a way more
effective than anybody else.
There's some very good
republicans in there,
some of them are quite
good policy wonks,
and one of them is going
to get the first call
to be my chief of
staff when I win.
- So, how you gonna
bring, I mean,
have you tried to talk to some
of them and be like, guys,
let's all coalesce around
somebody, I hope it's me.
- No, we haven't.
But what's happened, as
I've given interviews,
is they've tried to get me
to slice and dice my rivals
and I said I'm not playing that.
We should turn our cannon
fire towards the prize
and the prize is Gavin Newsom.
Keep our eye on the prize and
everything will be just fine.
I think the more the merrier.
I think everybody brings a
little bit of the audience,
a little bit of
intensity with them
and our intensity level versus
the democrats off the chart.
That's why I believe
we're gonna win.
- What do we do about taxes
in this ridiculous state?
- Well, I'm not gonna be able
to roll them back really,
because I'll be dealing
with 2/3 of the legislature.
We talked about it and
I've talked to a lot
of budget experts,
virtually almost all the
budget is on automatic pilot.
What I can do is stop bad stuff.
You'd be surprised how seldom
a government veto is overturned.
I checked when I first
started not to run.
I said, you they'll
overrun all my vetoes.
I didn't realize Arnold
Schwarzenegger vetoed,
hundreds of bills, not a
single one was overwritten.
There hasn't been
a veto overwritten
since the early '70s,
the first of the two terms
that Jerry Brown had.
- What's the possible
reasoning for that?
Just cause they
don't want to work?
- Because the bills
are so stupid,
once you veto them, you
hold a press conference,
explain why people put
pressure on their local senator
or their local assembly person
and all of a sudden
they back down,
they don't defend the bills.
So I can at least stop
bad stuff from happening.
I can stop single payer.
That's what they
would love to do
if they can get away with it.
I can stop that.
I can stop some of these
kinds of things and as I said,
I can use my emergency
powers to suspend CEQA,
my emergency powers
so that I can unleash
the power of builders.
I'm told by several builders,
there are 500,000 units right
on the board, ready to go.
All you have to do is
just lift the injunctions
and we're ready to go.
- Larry, we got a mask
mandate here in LA again.
- All against science.
It's LA county and the LA
county sheriff, Alex Villanueva.
I talked to him a few days
ago, said this is anti-science.
I'm not going to use my
manpower to enforce it.
What does that tell you?
What does it tell you?
This man, Gavin Newsom,
has imposed all these mandates
completely against science.
These guys are all about
science until they're not.
- So this woman, Barbara Ferrer,
who is the one that actually
put this mandate in place,
what do we do
about that elected?
Is she elected, I'm not
even sure if she's elected.
What do we do about that
layer of these people?
Like the woman who, you know,
voted to shut down all
the restaurants outdoors,
but they knew it wasn't going
to kick in for 48 hours,
so then she ate outdoors.
I protested at her
house that day.
I didn't want to
do it at her house,
but that's where
they were doing it.
I don't like bringing it to
people's houses obviously,
but that that's where--
- Didn't have a choice.
- But point is what do we do
about that class of people?
Because those guys seem
to be pulling the levers
in some ways, more
than Garcetti.
I don't hear him say
anything about LA anymore.
I mean, he's on
his way to India.
- Again, one of the
thing I'm going to have
is the bully pulpit.
I'll be able to talk
about people like that.
And one of the other things
I was told when I become
governor is to empower
the republicans up there.
I know they're outnumbered,
but if you tell the
democrat lawmakers, look,
if you don't get bipartisan,
buy-in, I'm going to veto.
And so all of a sudden the bill
to come much more sensible,
they involve the
republicans to the degree
they never had before.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to
empower republicans.
I want to give them backbone.
I think that's one of the
things Donald Trump did
by being so politically
incorrect and telling the truth.
He said, what do you have
to lose to black people
and they begin to say,
what do I have to lose?
What do you have to lose?
I saw a guy when I
was in the bay area,
just on a campaign thing,
poop in the middle of the
street and then devour his poop.
Do we have to do this,
do we have to watch this?
This guy needs help and
it's not helping him.
It's not helping the
homeless population.
We need to do something
about all of this stuff
and I'm going to do that.
- Elder, because you
are a professional,
you are a broadcasting pro,
not like a lot of the
people I bring in here,
you're a broadcasting
professional.
There's a camera right there.
Tell that camera where you
can go and final statement.
- I can't remember the website,
but I think it's
electelder.com, electelder.com.
I'm going to need your help.
That top maximum
individual contribution,
as I was just telling
Dave, is $34,200.
So please, please, please,
some of you rich people
out there max out,
and some of the people outside
of California who are very,
very wealthy billionaires,
millionaires,
many of you left
because of all of this.
Set up a PAC or give
your money to a PAC
that's got a philosophy
along the lines of mine.
Let's turn this date around
because we have a state to save.
Electelder.com, electelder.com.
Do you like this outfit?
My girlfriend wasn't here
to tell me what to wear,
so I took a chance
and I did the orange.
I did the orange
kind of blue thing.
I'm not sure that works. Yeah.
- All right, I'm going to
host a fundraiser here.
Now, I've said it publicly,
so I have to do it.
- Is Dave on the record
saying 342 maxing out?
- I gotta talk to my
accountant, he's in the back.
Thanks, my friend.
- Thank you, thank you.
And thank you so
much for bringing me
to a whole new audience
of young people.
You've often talked about
the interview where you feel
that you've kind of had your
assumptions torn asunder,
but you also elevated
me to another level
of popularity that
I did not have.
I think I told you before,
a young person suggested
I interview with you.
I didn't know who you were.
They said Larry, get your
head out of your, you know,
take the poll out.
This guy is the man,
he's cutting edge
and you exposed me to a whole
generation of young people
who did not know who I was.
So I also blame
you for my feeling
that I can turn around
some of these young people,
because a lot of people wrote
me in and look in the comments
I saw you on Dave Rubin,
I saw you and Dave Rubin.
I thought the way Dave did
and when you told him about
the stats regarding the police,
that the are more likely
to do to be hesitant,
to pull the trigger on a black
suspect and the white, like,
I didn't really realize that,
I went back and I saw the stats.
And so thank you so much, Dave,
for introducing me
to a whole audience
that I'd never would
have known, but for you.
- Larry, we're in this thing
together, we really are.
And you were telling me how
much you love comics before
and I got my comic collection
right there and it's like,
we're in the
Avengers now together
and we got a bad enemy to
fight, but they beat Thanos,
I think we're going
to be all right.
- That's right.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists
all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.